(upbeat music)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing Show,
the number one podcast for
growing and scaling your business
with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell,
and we're from Think Media,
and if this is your first
time listening, welcome.
- This show's dedicated
to helping you learn
how to get your content noticed,
and the latest money-making strategies
working right now online.
So, whether you want to
grow your YouTube channel
or maximize online video
across social media,
this is for you.
Well, today we have a
special treat for you.
We have Omar El-Takrori from
the Think Media team here.
- Super pumped, excited to be here.
- And Omar has really gotten
us into video podcasting,
and a few months at Grow with Video Live,
our annual conference that
we host here in Las Vegas,
you shared a really awesome keynote.
Tell us about it.
- Yeah, so, essentially what I shared
was just a case study of one of my clients
and how their video podcast
has been able to help
grow their online sales
from 30k to over $250,000 a month
in just eight months.
And so that's just 30
grand month over month
simply implementing video
podcasts for their business.
And so I think this is encouraging,
'cause a lot of the
things that I'm sharing,
you could apply in your business,
in your YouTube channel,
in your podcast.
Even if you're thinking about,
if you've dabbled with the idea
of starting your own podcast
and essentially how to even get started,
there's a lot of information there.
But, yeah, I'm super excited for everybody
to check this one out.
- Yeah, so here's your
all-access, VIP, front-row seats
to the recording from Omar's keynote
at Grow with Video Live.
- Today I wanna talk to you
about why you need to
start a video podcast,
and we're gonna talk
about a business I took
in just a few short months
growing 30k a month in online sales,
month over month,
and then also growing
their YouTube channel
to 14,000 subscribers in just nine months.
So let's get started.
Today's objective, or
this session's objective,
is I just wanna give you
reasons, using this case study.
You know, Sean said this earlier
that reasons come before results,
and I think before you see results,
the thing that'll actually
keep you going is your reasons.
And so I wanna also give you tips
on how to start your video podcast.
And the purpose of this is that
I would leave you convinced
to start a podcast so
you can make more money.
Nobody in this room
wants to make more money?
I'm just kidding.
(audience cheers) So
you can make more money
and build your brand authority.
Digital audio accounts
for the biggest share
of time spent on mobile
with social media and
digital video following.
Sean shared that, and then.
And so that goes to say that video podcast
is the ultimate strategy,
because when done right,
it fills all the things above.
It fills the audio aspect of things,
it fills the social
media aspect of things,
and then it fills the online
video aspect of things.
You know, it's funny
because we say link in bio,
but we forgot that it stands
for link in biography.
Just, okay.
Link in bio.
My name is Omar El-Takrori.
In 2007, I chose broadcast journalism
as my elective in high school.
You guys are like, "Dang, he's young."
Or you guys are like,
"Dang, he's not old, but."
(audience laughs)
I really enjoyed it.
I really enjoyed shooting videos.
I enjoyed doing podcasts,
not podcasts, like PSAs,
and fun announcements for our high school.
And I bought my own camera
and pirated Sony Vegas,
because I was only in high school.
I didn't know how to buy stuff.
And then I just got to go.
I just started editing
videos and creating content.
I started vlogging in 2007,
didn't make money by 2008, and so I quit.
(audience laughs)
I have a family, that's facts.
This is a picture of my fam.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Yeah, family.
Go families.
This is Amanda and little Ruby Grace.
A little bit more.
I have an agency that does
content creation for businesses
and offers YouTube strategy
to help grow businesses' audiences,
and I also work at Think
Media as lead content creator,
and then I also have a YouTube channel
where I teach beginner
photography and videography.
I don't put too much effort into it,
but just the power tip
that I've applied VRA.
I've applied VRA to my channel,
and with just 12 videos,
I have 16,000 subscribers.
I'm not tryna plug anything
other than strategy works, guys.
This VRA thing is really legit,
and so if you even haven't taken VRA,
really reconsider,
'cause posting all these
videos onto YouTube
or posting it wherever you wanna post it
without having strategy,
it's gonna be very frustrating.
All right, so meet Mike and Shauna Jones.
Look how good looking they are.
All the spray tan.
No, I'm just kidding.
(audience laughs)
We met back in (laughs).
We met back in 2015.
I was working at a church
as a creative director,
but also helping with small groups
as being small group coaches,
and so I was assigned to
coach their small group.
They had a small group
that met in their house,
and they just talked
about life every week.
And then I remember they
were during that time,
Shauna was doing lash
extensions out of her house,
and, I mean, I also knew them enough
that they were grinding.
I knew that it wasn't an easy
life that they were living,
but nonetheless, they decided
to give a night of their week
to encourage people in our church
and have 'em over, have some pizza.
And so this is just a
picture of their house,
room set up where Shauna doing lashes,
and Mike's doing mortgages at the time,
so this is 2014, 2015.
And she would hustle.
She would spend hours,
you know, during the night
on Instagram, following
girls in the industry.
And what that means is
simply girls that work
at the pools here and the clubs.
Girls that if you can
get fresh lashes on 'em,
they'll probably tell their friends,
and then they'll probably hit up Shauna.
Just a little, that costed nothing,
but just hours of her time at night.
They had a hard time paying the bills.
They have a funny story
where they were, you know,
they're paying rent, and they
couldn't make rent one month,
so they sold their
refrigerator to make rent.
And it's just crazy things
like that to think that
they have just a gnarly story,
and they just grinded, man.
They saw that there
was some promise there,
they felt like there was something there,
and so with hard work,
and they really just went
all in on their business,
in 2015 they opened up their
first salon here in Vegas.
And just fast forwarding
two-and-a-half years,
they now have three
salons here in Las Vegas.
(audience member cheers)
You give that up.
That's pretty gnarly.
(audience applauds)
They have, so, three salons in
Las Vegas across the Valley,
100 lash artists are working under them.
They also have a training course
that certifies lash artists.
So, they're bringing people
into the industry, too,
through their brand.
And so essentially these are
all things they had in place
prior to, you know, going
in with video podcasting
or even YouTube.
And so I just wanna, I just
wanted to paint this picture
of maybe there's an
aspect to your business
that you're missing
that could probably
help your video podcast
really pour in fire into your flame.
Or is it gasoline into the fire?
Yeah, something like that.
All right.
So here's some things
that every business needs
in order, I think, to stay
relevant and stay effective.
They are practitioners.
The first thing is practitioners.
You can also put this, like, services.
So, they are boots on ground.
This allows anybody to stay relevant
and also be on top of trends.
So, I'm a content creator myself,
but if I just stop taking photos
and I stop doing video just
because I grow out of it,
then I'll start speaking into an industry,
and I'll just be the old guy
that's using old terminology
and still talking about DSLR cameras
when mirrorless cameras
are the thing to do.
And so, you know, the practitioner aspect
of their business helps
them stay relevant.
Secondly, products.
Do you have something to sell?
Raise your hand if you
have something to sell.
Awesome, that's half the room.
So you got, 50% of this
room needs to work on
physical product or a digital product.
And I don't think you have
to overthink it, either.
I think just a quick power tip,
you can record yourself do one thing
and sell it as a
pay-per-view in its entirety.
So, whatever that is.
If that's, you know, a
consultation for someone
getting their eyes
checked, the full process,
somebody recorded you, it's
15 bucks on your website.
Just a thought.
The third thing is they're professors.
It's a stretch.
I just wanted to do three Ps,
'cause I wanna keep it consistent.
But essentially they
have an educational wing
to their business.
Do you have an educational
wing to your business?
Three things that you
can have on your business
that can just create an ecosystem,
'cause people can meet
you at the education,
they can stay in your world
'cause you're offering them supplies,
and then you're still doing services,
so you're staying up on trends,
so as they keep learning from you,
you're staying up on trends.
Amen.
So, just Mike hits me up.
This is like a year ago.
He's like, "Hey, Omar, how
does your YouTube channel
"have so many subscribers,
"but you upload zero videos?"
(audience laughs)
And I told him, I was like,
"It's the power of
making searchable content
"for an audience that
I have predetermined,
"which was beginner
photographers and videographers."
And he's like, "Could you do that for us?"
And I was like, "Nah, man.
"This is too valuable,
"'cause if you hire me
and we apply these things,
"you can cut me off at any time,
"and this will keep working
for you forever and ever."
He's like, "Let's go grab lunch."
And he asked me again, and I was like,
"All right, man, let's do it."
And so, always ask twice, you never know.
So, we started a video podcast,
and we picked a day to
shoot all the podcasts.
This is what we can call batching, right?
So this is what they had January 1st,
before we started doing their
YouTube channel video podcast.
They had 30 subscribers,
'cause they uploaded iPhone videos,
and all their lash artists subscribed.
(audience member laughs)
(Omar laughs)
They're in the room,
and that's why they're
laughing so hard. Okay.
They had zero podcast streams,
because they weren't doing it.
And they were doing 30k
a month in online sales,
probably for the last six months of 2018,
so that's a screenshot
of their December sales,
which was 29 grand.
How we did it.
We bought the gear.
That's the first step.
You gotta buy the gear in order to do it,
but don't overthink it.
We also, we just simply
shot this in one angle.
Straight-on angle, and I shot it in 4k.
Most of our phones in this
room actually shoot 4k.
And then I edited it at 1080p project.
I know that probably flew
over some people's heads.
Essentially, I filmed it
really high resolution,
and then I edited it at
a smaller resolution,
so it makes it look like
we have multiple angles.
And I'll show you an
example in just a second.
Then we captured the
audio on a Zoom recorder.
Edited each episode straight through.
This alleviated the headache.
We're not trying to cut
videos or cut content
so it came over quickly.
It was just like, "All right, ready?
"All right, here we go.
"Start the show, hit record.
"And then end the show, hit record."
And then the edit was just that simple.
- In celebration of the launch
of this brand-new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference,
Grow with Video Live, a $1,500 value.
- All you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe,
leave us a review on Apple Podcast,
and then take a screenshot of your review
and go to ThinkMarketingShow.com
for the rest of the details.
- Content without strategy is just stuff.
So you wanna make sure you got strategy.
You put out all this stuff.
I say this.
If you have the best product
and nobody knows about it,
guess what, friend?
You don't have the best product.
Someone could have 50% good of
product that you offer maybe,
and because more people
know about it, I'm sorry,
they have the better product.
That's just the reality.
So who wants to know what they got now?
(audience cheers)
'Cause everybody likes the
transformation. (laughs)
So, right now they have
14,200 subscribers.
(audience cheers)
Yeah, let's give it up.
(audience cheers and applauds)
That's 14,000 people that
understand what they're following.
That's 14,000 potential lash artists,
people who are in the beauty industry
that wanna start their own businesses.
It's a pretty strong audience to have.
They have 56,000 podcast streams.
From zero.
That's incredible.
And as of August, they've done 220 sales
in just online sales.
(audience cheers and applauds)
That's 30k month over month.
Turn up.
Just breaking that down
just a little bit deeper.
14,200 subscribers, what does that mean?
That means, and I would say imagine this
for your own business.
I know I'm sharing this example.
How cool would it be if
you had 400,000 minutes
spent on your brand?
2.5 million minutes watched?
They're in your world, you
have 2.5 million minutes
spent in your brand world, your
business, whatever that is.
That's pretty powerful.
And just a power tip,
Google Ad Sense already,
they're gonna make 2,100
bucks as of this point,
which I would say was the
cost of the podcast equipment
we went to go with.
So they already made a
return on their investment
on the podcast setup.
Turn up for the ROI.
And another cool thing,
real-time activity.
At any given time in 48 hours,
there's about 8,200 people
watching their content.
So, as of right now, maybe
there's like 2,000 people
just on their stuff.
They're here in the audience,
and they're chilling,
but they got strategy.
56,000 podcast streams.
What this looks at, this
is 4,000 listens a week.
They drop one podcast episode a week,
and they're getting 4,000 listens.
Average episode is about 15 minutes.
So, you can imagine.
You got 4,000 people
listening to you for an hour every month.
Pretty powerful.
And then growing by 30 grand.
What does that really mean?
That means they made a
ton of money. (laughs)
That also means that 15
people are in their store
at any given time.
Their Shopify. You can just hop up on,
and it just says that
15 people are in there.
That's pretty crazy.
Returning customer rate's about 70,
and what that speaks of
is that people trust them.
And it's because they've been able
to give away all this free value.
There's other lash brands.
There's other lash companies,
there's other lash supplies.
But because they're the ones
telling you how to do this stuff,
and never do they ever
say, "Buy our stuff,"
they're just like, "Yo,
we're gonna be doing these,
"this wispy lash look.
"I'll be using these
tweezers and this glue.
"Let's get into it."
And then people just,
"All right, I might as
well just buy it from them,
"because I trust them."
Tips for your first episode.
Just some tips for your first
episode of your podcast.
The strategy aspect of things.
So, when we first started the podcast,
he wanted to share, Mike
wanted to share the story
of how they came to where they are.
And so he's like, "Dude,
let's title this podcast
"The Struggle is Real,
"'cause that's, man,
the struggle is real."
And I was like, "That's dope,
"but nobody's searching
the struggle is real."
Right?
So I went on YouTube.
And I saw that people were searching
how to start a lash
business with no money.
Which essentially was their story,
so that was the title
of their video that we,
of the first,
their first podcast that they put out.
And we did the research.
That's simply research before
you press record, right?
And so do the research.
Your podcasts could be reverse engineered.
So don't just go out there and talk about
what you wanna talk about.
See, based off of what
you wanna talk about,
go ahead and search what you wanna search,
and see what people are searching.
And you can learn all this through VRA.
We learned that probably
when you start off,
you wanna start with volume.
So, we started with eight
podcasts for the first two months.
So, we dropped two episodes
every week for every month.
That may sound like a lot for you guys,
but I would actually disagree,
because we shot those all in one day.
And power tip to them, power tip to me.
But at the same time, it's doable.
Just hunker down and
get 'er done. (laughs)
I don't know why I said that, okay.
(Omar laughs)
Okay.
And then another thing
that they did up front,
and it's something you can do,
is they did a giveaway every episode.
So, it was about a month-long giveaway,
and when they announced the
winner the following episode,
they started a new giveaway,
and it increased shareability,
it grew the email list for the podcast.
But you can give away
something during the episode.
Another thing is, this may
be obvious, may be not be,
but post your podcasts.
If you film 'em, if you record them,
post them on YouTube, and
post them to podcasts.
You create the standard
for what your audience expects from you.
I think this is powerful,
because I wrote it.
I'm just kidding.
(audience laughs)
Wow, Omar, chill, bro.
Ah, no, it's fresh, though.
What I mean by that is
because we started off
with long-form content,
people met them with long-form content,
and nobody will expect less from you.
And so, with every episode
being about 15 minutes,
sometimes 20, sometimes 12,
nobody's expecting less.
I would actually say on Think Media,
we're fighting for attention,
because it's different kinds of content,
but we also didn't start off this way.
So, if you have yet to start,
it's not a bad idea to start
with longer-form content,
because if people stumble on your stuff,
find value, they won't expect
anything less from you.
Thank you.
So, what are some lessons
we learned so far?
Number one, that there's
a massive opportunity
for your business and brand
to be on a, have a podcast.
Secondly is that there's
a people waiting for you.
I think sometimes we forget that.
We make it all about us.
Like, I don't have this, I look like this,
but legit, there's people
waiting for content
that is coming from your perspective,
coming from your experiences,
and things like that.
And so, think about the people.
I think that alleviates
the pressure altogether
in the sense that there
is a group of people
that need this stuff.
I need to get it into their hands.
Podcasts can be monetized.
We definitely learned that.
I would say before I tapped into the world
of online marketing and
networking and stuff
that I always thought podcasts
were such a free thing,
and the way we monetize this, obviously,
is they have the supply chain.
This can also be monetized
if they wanna sell ad space
on their podcasts.
We actually, though, use it, they use it
for their own promotion.
So they self-promote.
Which you notice.
They promote their classes on there,
and they promote speaking engagements.
They've also been invited to
speak at LashCon this October,
which is pretty crazy.
(audience applauds)
And why is it so important
for your business?
Raise your hand if you
struggle with consistency.
Let's get it, everybody in the room.
This is an easy way of
getting content done.
One-shot angle, talk straight through
if you have your points dialed in maybe,
or maybe you just have the general idea
of what you wanna talk about,
but again, if you're just
starting off, just go for it.
It doesn't have to be polished.
Another reason is 'cause
it gives you the ability
to repurpose the content,
which Sean just talked about.
Like, you can cut up five
pieces of micro content
from your podcast episode,
not having to ever sit down
again in front of the camera,
but because it's shot, it's put together,
you can now dish out
content on other platforms.
And then it also builds trust.
I think the coolest thing
is they just haven't had to sell anything.
They're just like, "Yo,
this is how you do stuff.
"This is what we've experienced.
"This is how we do our
things here at our company."
And it's that jab jab, right hook
from Gary V. mentality,
where if they really
wanna ask, they'll ask,
but they actually don't need to.
But when they do, it's gonna be awesome,
because people are gonna be like,
"For sure, we'll go to that live event,
"because we've been following
you guys for two years,
"I can't wait to come here."
And I think there's a
handful of us here right now
because Sean has hit you a little bit
with the jab jabs.
Sorry.
Oh, another good reason is
you reach two types of people.
Simply making a video podcast,
People who listen to podcasts,
and people who are on YouTube.
You hack watch-listen times,
simply what I talked about,
that just because it's longer form,
you get to win on that end.
And then here's just a legit stat
that there's over 500 million
active users on YouTube,
versus less than one million podcasts.
So that's just a number to keep in mind
that shows that there's so
much opportunity in this phase.
So, conclusion, start podcasting now.
(audience cheers)
Make some noise if you
gonna start your podcast.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Thanks for checking out this episode.
We hope you got a ton of value,
and if you haven't already,
subscribe here to the Think Marketing Show
wherever you're watching or listening.
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review
this show on Apple Podcast.
- As we grow this movement
of purpose-driven content creators,
we encourage you to
share it with a friend.
And we'll see you in the next episode.
(upbeat music)